hello everyone my name is Brian I work
on Google cloud and we're gonna talk
about where should I run my code
deciding between all these pieces so I'm
curious how many people here write code
today okay lots of lots of hands this is
what maybe 80% how many people keep
systems running like okay another maybe
30 40 % and how many people tell other
people what to do like coordinate work
that kind of thing ok another 20 30 % so
lots of people here do multiple things
thank you for coming and I think this
will be useful to all of those roles so
developer operations managers all
together so this question where should I
run my code and the answer is of course
it depends and so this talk will talk
about all the different ways that it
depends at Google cloud we have a lot of
blue hexagons you've seen a lot of low
hexagons today we're going to talk
mostly about these four and going to
kind of start from the bottom up so
compute engine are our virtual machines
container engine is hosted kubernetes so
orchestration for containers App Engine
is our platform as a service
give us code we'll run it and cloud
functions are kind of that internet glue
you just give a function definition and
it runs so I'm gonna make a claim that
there's you can use each of these things
for many different things there's
overlapping things but there's a sweet
spot the kind of the the best happy spot
in for each of these and I claim that
compute engine is an excellent fit for
any existing system so you've got a
large completed system that runs lots of
different pieces you can it's probably
running on virtual machines or on like
hardware today and you can move that
over pretty much directly
if you have a system that is containers
first like you've got all docker images
and you're set up good to go and you
have a lot of those you want to keep
track of them container engine
kubernetes is gonna be a really good fit
for that if your application is
primarily web HTTP request/response app
engine is an excellent fit and if you're
trying to respond to events asynchronous
events and you just don't want to think
about the rest cloud functions is
awesome
so this is the claim I'm gonna make and
we're gonna go like I said bottom up so
VMs containers has functions and then
actually answer the question seriously
where should I run my code and then
we're gonna have Ellie from loom apps
come up and talk about their decision
and how they decided between these
before they existed so start off with
compute engine and compute engine always
our virtual machines infrastructure is a
surface it is
compute network disk we have all sorts
of specifics the machines can get quite
large 96 GPUs 8 sorry 96 CPUs 8 GPUs
lots of RAM lots of disk and you can
make a VM which with each of these
almost independent like so you can have
a machine with very large memory and
relatively small CPU if that's what you
need for your application they start
very quickly about 30 seconds and we
have lots of base images already that
you can use to use the operating system
that you are familiar with and then you
can make your own images from those I
wanted to talk about the disk a little
bit so these are virtual machines right
we all know how virtual machines work
except in the cloud things can work a
little differently so the disk for
example this bigger disks
are faster in the sense of more
throughput so if you're doing any kind
of testing like perfect testing you want
to see what's gonna be fast is this fast
enough for you
larger discs are actually higher
throughput because you're getting a
slice of all of these different discs in
the data center and a bigger disc gives
you a bigger slice so you actually have
more physical disks working for you the
larger the disk is so that's maybe not
obvious and it's more than just VMS so
we have an optimized OS that you can use
to just run one container so if you want
to run a docker image you can boot up a
VM that's the setup for doing that we
have this system called managed instance
groups so instead of thinking about one
computer you can think about a pool of
identical computers and when you do that
you each of them is created from the
same template and so you can make that
pool bigger or smaller and you just have
a dial for I'd like more computers doing
this processing or fewer and that allows
auto scaling so you can hook that up to
traffic or CPU metrics and have it scale
the pool via those or use that to spread
it across multiple zones so if one zone
goes down you still have the same number
of computers running because it will
scale up in another zone and you can use
it for rolling updates if you have a new
version of the template you can actually
drop one machine off add another one
drop another one off add another new one
and use that to kind of roll to a new
version of your base image that you're
using and then our load balancer when
you use compute engine or container
engine a pinch and all the way up the
load balancer is actually configuring
Google's data centers so you're using
the same load balancer we use for
YouTube and for maps and the like so you
get to configure it and go it's pretty
fun so when you're using this you are
thinking about your software
you're thinking about the operating
system you want to run how much memory
network disk you need and the networking
rules how the pieces talk to each other
all of that is things you need to
consider and it's it's the things you're
used to thinking about in IT right and
there's api's for all of this it is a
particularly good fit when you have an
existing system you're gonna kind of
lift something up and shift it to
another place this container optimized
VM if you want to just run one image one
docker image it's very handy if you need
a very specific kernel or very specific
operating system you may have license
requirements that push you like you're
only allowed to run say four CPUs you
know for the licensing and the same
machine so you can use that it's handy
for running databases and if you need
like very specific Network protocols
we'll see some of the other options only
run HTTP HTTPS each of the VM starts in
about 30 seconds
so that's your kind of scaling you can
run thousands of VMs and 62 like in a
minute to 2 minutes kind of time frame
and it's up to you to decide how you
upgrade update your software update your
OS security patches all of that work is
still in your world you have direct
control and responsibility for for
managing that so demo too much talking
let's go and try something out so this a
this is Google cloud platform I'm gonna
show you if how many is this relatively
new you haven't done too much look at
the web site how many people ok maybe
this won't be so exciting but the secret
to Google cloud platform is this
hamburger button everything is in the
hamburger but that's where all of the
different features of Google Cloud are
so and we will look at compute engine
when I actually have some things set up
for later demos and we can create a new
instance yay
I'm going to pick a nearby European data
center and we can of course choose from
some kind of setup pre-configured sized
machines or sorry wrong link or click
customize and we get a slider for how
many CPU cores do you want how much
memory do you want we can we can max
them all the way up but I have a
specific size in mind it's kind of what
I think I was maybe the answer so that's
the machine we're gonna build here and
you can also this is where you would set
if you wanted to run GPUs and like you
can choose the base operating system I'm
just going to go ahead and use what are
the pre-made Debian machines we have but
you can also kind of pick from this
whole list of the different Apple is
including Windows suzay Red Hat and the
like so well hit create when I hit
create there it's actually made an HTTP
request off to the back end and it's
allocating a new set part of a set of
hardware somewhere it's connecting this
disk image to the machine booting the
machine up and then if I had set it up
to could start to run my code once it
comes up so oh hey good in demo fashion
it finished quickly and I just wanted to
show you this button here this is the
SSH button and what this does is since
I'm logged in to the web interface I
have already done an OAuth
authentication Google knows who I am and
it will push SSH keys to the instance so
that we can login over SSH and you can
do this from the command line
or from the web and it's a real computer
we can can prove that's a real computer
because we have scrolling text thank you
for laughing at that but basically you
can SSH right from the web so that's a
like a really quick tour of compute
engine so why might you choose compute
engine consistency if you do a test with
ten VMs next week you should see the
same behavior the same performance with
ten VMs or in another region the same
behavior you can choose exactly the
shape of VM and this is really handy for
existing systems instead of trying to
optimize or get a bunch of different
pieces of software to cut you know work
on the same machine because it happens
to have 128 gigs of ram you can give one
machine 32 and the other 96 and just
keep them separate with exactly how much
they need to be happy I will guess that
everyone in here has had a computer run
out of disk and fail at some point in
their life you can actually resize disks
that are attached to VMs and make them
larger and then update the partition you
know in most OS is update all the way
through the OS so it sees the additional
space and actually give it space while
it's alive which is fun and then our
billing is set up to be as easy as
possible to reason about to understand
automatically give you discounts when
you use it over time that's or thing we
also move these VMs like if we have
planned updates to the hardware or the
the host operating systems will actually
move the VMs to another machine and it's
almost unnoticeable usually in the
single-digit millisecond pause all the
network traffic makes it through comes
back up it's actually on new hardware
and we continue on and it's a really
natural fit for many existing systems so
compute engine it's awesome and if
you're using container engine or app
and flex all of those are actually
running we use compute engine as the
base for running these as well so all of
the benefits I talked about so far you
get in these other tools as well so next
this is gonna be kind of gonna keep
going container engine more questions
how many people are using containers
docker something like that already okay
that's maybe 40 50 percent of the room
that's awesome and I'm gonna just assume
everybody is else is interested and so
we're all in so the short version of
containers why it solves the well it
worked on my machine why doesn't it work
in production problem very nicely it
also gives you a nice isolation between
different processes so they can't hurt
each other so they have all their
dependencies and they're kind of
insulated from each other and this
enables all sorts of good things that
you're probably aware of
once you decide you're all in on
containers then you could end up with
hundreds or thousands of containers and
that's where kubernetes comes in and it
is an open source orchestration system
for managing lots of containers it lets
you treat a cluster of machines as one
thing and you say run this for me and
the cluster figures out where to put it
and if one of them goes down it figures
out where to start a new one so it keeps
things set up the way you want it to be
it's open source
there's the found open buy owned by a
foundation like just a few days ago the
docker announced that they're including
kubernetes and their distribution in the
future
it is really worth looking at ok so
we're using kubernetes what do you think
about your thinking about your
application and I like to when you get
into a meeting room with other with your
colleagues you've got a whiteboard and
you're drawing lines and boxes between
the different parts of the system and
kubernetes actually lets you reason
about your system in a very similar
level of abstraction when you're making
a config file
you say this component I want five of
them running and it uses this other
piece by name and kubernetes figures out
how to connect them to each other how to
do the networking so you get to live at
this kind of whiteboard level thinking
and push the configuration down to the
computers at that level of abstraction
so that's really powerful container
engine is Google clouds hosted version
of kubernetes so we run the cluster for
you we upgrade keep the nodes up-to-date
update to new versions of the host and
scale the size the cluster for you up
and down it's a very good fit for any
situation where you need to insulate
yourself from the environment so you
want to run the same application say on
your own machines or in a cloud in
another cloud in China you know like and
you need it to work the same way it's
also very useful to have consistent
behavior through dev tests production
and you know basically get high
utilization out of your systems because
you can have more code running on them
it's a really good fit when you you know
when you know you're going to use lots
of containers so you're you can take
full advantage of them and the ephemeral
nature it does I'm going to say it's a
good fit for but this is also kind of a
requirement of needing good team
communication so between your dev your
ops and your security teams because the
code is displayed in these images if you
want to make a security fix to that code
you need to be in the same pipeline that
the developers are using you know make
the changes in the compatible way so
probably you want a continuous
integration system of some kind of build
system and you want good communication
between the different parts of your
organization it requires you to use
containers so it is only for
containerized software and if you need
things like per machine licensing it can
get a little challenging and the like so
so that's there
the quickie version I'm gonna now will
do it of this so this is the overall UI
for container engine because this is a
talk this is kind of like a cooking show
I've prepared the cluster already it's
already running and we click on this
there's some information about the
cluster here but the main thing I wanted
to show you is down here instance groups
it's actually using the manage instance
of compute engine to set the size the
pool so we're just using regular compute
engine features to do that there is a
dashboard built into the open source
communities tool it looks like this and
I currently have nothing deployed behind
this load balancer so there's a public
IP address here and which I guess if
every writes quickly you could look at
and there's nothing running there right
now so we can quickly say cue CTL run
something named nginx based off an image
a docker image nginx and this is a
webserver that's very commonly used and
that's already deployed so if we take a
look over here we actually already have
this thing called a deployment of pod
and I'm not gonna go into names too much
but this pod is one process running
nginx and in fact over here in this
window we're already seeing that network
connection actually finished and we got
the default web serving page we can also
scale and then say we want to actually
have say 12 of these and by the time I
get back over here to refresh I didn't
even catch it with some of them starting
there actually all running up and going
so that's a really quick feel for
kubernetes
so we talked about these things
basically it's very useful to insulate
you from the other infrastructure it
enables higher utilization so that you
can the more processes you have running
the higher percentage of the CPU you're
using the less money you're spending
overall and it is a really nice
abstraction spot for many folks okay
next up is App Engine so App Engine is
our platform as a surface
it lets developers focus on the code
they're writing and then we handle the
rest I think we could say it was
serverless early on so App Engine has
been around for six seven years now
actually starting 2008 so more and the
trade-off for App Engine has always been
if you write your app in this particular
way then give us the code and we'll
scale it up and down from zero traffic
to millions of requests per second and
we can we can make that happen just
recently we've announced and released
the App Engine flexible environment
which takes the good stuff from App
Engine and lets you write you know run
any docker image and have that managed
by App Engine so you can take and run
whatever language you want to use any
specific C libraries you need these
things that were kind of limitations in
the previous version of App Engine and
you can run them and it also means you
can you know kind of take advantage of
the containerization you've been doing
in other places so pretty much if it
runs in a docker container you can run
it on App Engine flex when you're using
App Engine you're thinking about the
code that you've written in Python or go
whatever language you're using the HTTP
requests and responses and the version
of your code and that's about it
there's no servers there's that you need
to worry about you can focus directly on
your business needs as I said before
it's a really good fit
it's meant for serving websites websites
or HTTP api's you know anything that's
HTTP based scales very well to high
traffic the the standard version we have
run times for several languages but you
cannot add your own kind of binary
extensions to it and then the Flex
version basically anything you can do in
docker you can do there today it's not
the best fit for sites that go down to
almost no traffic because flex has a
minimum of two VMs so you end up paying
for two VMs out of the covers all the
time whereas standard will scale down to
zero and paid nothing if there's no
traffic so a quickie demo of App Engine
so this is the App Engine dashboard for
a site that I have that was made by a
colleague Justin Beckwith and it serves
up an image of fruit it's the whole
website but there are multiple versions
of this website because some people like
different fruit and we've argued about
this a little bit we did some user
research to figure out what the most
popular fruit is let's do something
right now how many people here like
durian actually this is it like I'm not
even sure that's an English word much
less translates over let's go ahead and
switch the site because we we know
durian is a very popular fruit we're
gonna actually migrate all the traffic
from this site to a new version of the
website that serves up a different fruit
and if i refresh the page that look
familiar
what does that in French I didn't quite
hear that but it's awesome maybe I think
people love or hate durian right but we
can we can switch the version that
quickly and you can roll back to a
previous version like if we want to go
back to cherry because I was wrong about
how popular it is we can revert back to
a previous version very easily and we
can also
kind of split the traffic where we say
we're gonna do you know 80% Apple and
22% durian or whatever we'd like to do
so that's a fun thing you can do because
you've got the hosted environment
okay so App Engine lets your developers
focus on code and we handle all the rest
you need to you so that's awesome and if
you add in the flexible runtimes that
means you can you can run any docker
image and you can also take that image
and run it other places so the same code
that you've you know made to run in App
Engine you can run in container engine
or on virtual machines or on your other
you know on your own machines actually
and even though this is fully managed
you can actually still SSH in and do
debugging and things if you need to via
flex and just for fun App Engine is used
a lot one hundred billion requests per
day on average last time we updated the
numbers so next up I'm just gonna keep
going cloud functions so this is
internet glue I'm gonna say and I think
it's you can use it in lots of different
ways but I think one of the most
powerful kind of easiest places to start
is for things that are event-driven
something happens you want to do some
processing you know do something else so
event process and just think of it as
like a it just starts a function call so
the events we can trigger off of our
pub/sub cloud storage and a straight
HTTP request and this isn't actually the
topic of the talk but if you're using
Google Cloud I highly recommend looking
into pub/sub and cloud storage they're
kind of like the glue between all the
different parts that you might you know
between the blue hexagons almost every
application uses cloud storage and
pub/sub in some fashion it's very very
useful so please check them out
cloud functions is fully managed you
have the function definition and you
just push that and we run it for you and
you only paper execution it is an open
kind of format we have a node.js runtime
that you can run on your own machines or
you can have hosted in cloud functions
so you can do local testing and run it
in other places so when you're using it
you're thinking about events and the
function definition and that's that's
kind of it it's a good fit when you want
to be like serverless upfront if you're
already using pub stub or storage you
don't want to think about the runtime
environment very much and it's basically
this glue constraints wise I'll very
carefully say there is one run time
today and where we're looking you know
that's no js' so JavaScript on nodejs
looking at other languages and it forces
you to think per function and sometimes
that's a real advantage and sometimes
that can get complicated if you have
lots of functions so kind of be careful
there and demo is less of a demo more
kind of just what this looks like this
is the cloud functions kind of overview
here let me actually go back so this is
a list of different functions I have
deployed I've got a hello world function
that as you might expect doesn't do very
much it has an HTTP URL that we can use
to trigger it so if I click on that it
will run it and do whatever the function
does
we gave it no parameters and this
function if you give it no parameters
just says no message I don't know what
to do with that
so what does this function look like we
can come and look at the source here and
we'll find out that if there's no body
it just returns this message we just saw
and if there is something it will
actually log that and
turn so it's kind of like an echo hello
world app so if I grab this we can
actually come over here so you can use
you can do testing via HTTP any way you
like but there's also kind of a built-in
let's just try this out tab so we can
say hello Paris click test the function
it will make that call we actually get a
success back and that's what it looks
like so there isn't that much to see in
functions but basically you take some
input you can do some work have a side
effect or not and then return some some
information back at the end so this is
just a function that lives in the cloud
and you can use it to connect different
pieces it's integrated with our logging
system centralized logging so you can
look at it here but you can also look at
it in stackdriver logging see what's
happening with them that sort of thing
ok so you think about functions you
don't have to think about servers you
just pay for what you use simple
developer experience ok seriously where
should I run my code did you find a good
fit already so as I was talking through
things did compute engine or container
engine jump out if so go take a look at
that research that play with that see
what it looks like probably though it
depends a little bit so here's a few
more things that you might consider in
addition to just what these tools are
the level of abstraction that it gives
you the technical requirements of your
application and the team that you have
your company the people you work with
what those look like so for example for
abstraction what happens is like what
level do you want to be thinking at so
if you have people that are more
developer or kind of like mindset you
might want to spend more time thinking
about code if you have a really
established operations group you may be
already wanting to think about container
or down into compute engine some
abstraction level technical requirements
so if you have specific needs if you
need a custom kernel to make your
application run you're probably going to
be looking at VMs down at compute engine
and so technical constraints may will
kind of push you down the abstraction
stack something that happens there and
then your team you know how do they
think about software how comfortable are
they with containers for example how
much existing code do you have that you
need to make sure it works and do you
have processes that need to work a very
specific way in your company and you may
need more flexibility to implement those
that may kind of push you down into the
details a bit sometimes okay so all
these different things how do you make
the right decision I'm gonna I'm gonna
claim no worries it's actually very easy
to switch between these levels if you're
in containers so that's the kind of if
they're so if if your application can
run in a docker container then awesome
and if you start at the App Engine level
so if you're starting a new project and
you start at a very high level of
abstraction if you want to move down
it's a change one config line and you go
from App Engine standard to Flex once
you're in Flex it creates a docker image
every time you deploy so you can take
that same docker image and you can run
that in container engine or you can run
that in compute engine so you can take
the exact same code and run it in all of
these environments already if you're
starting a compute engine if you go up
like you may have to there's some work
involved in getting it into containers
and then you can do the same thing you
can kind of move up the stack and decide
where you want to run it also most
systems that are mature they end up
using multiple parts of things you might
have an app engine front-end for your
web api and some kind of long-running
processes maybe do transcoding video
transcoding
or some other work in VMs so it's very
common to have a system that's made up
of using these together okay so back to
the very beginning if you've got an
event-driven problem start at cloud
functions if you are starting a new
thing you know you're going to be on the
web
start with App Engine if you're all-in
on containers kubernetes container
engine and if you have an existing
system you should probably start looking
at compute engine and that is the core
of that and I would like to hand over to
actually and this clicker for you
thank you thank you
move autos as you could understand I
could have done this presentation in
French but I want Brian to understand it
so I will do it in English as well so my
name is Eddie Mira I am one of the
co-founders and CTU of few Maps and I'm
really glad to be here today to tell you
more about our journey using Google
cloud platform it's been more than five
years now so first what what is lu maps
so lu maps is the omni cooperate and
social portal recommended by Google and
it's fully integrated with Google G
suite so it's basically everything you
need to work in one place and our goal
is to make sure that you will never need
your old intranet again so Lu Maps is a
social mobile and smart intranet and to
connect and engage employees it brings
all your internal communication in just
a central hub so corporate news business
applications including G suite and
social collaboration it's built on top
of G suite and it integrates with the
directory with groups with Drive with
Gmail with calendar with sites and much
more and we are really proud at
Maps to have a team one Android person
dedicated to the Google cloud platform
and you know being a recommended Google
partner means that we work Google and
loom apps together to align all the
product roadmaps and as you can see our
solution has been adapted already by
major G suite customers so for instance
Colgate Logitech and also as I've
recently joined the loom apps family so
just to give you a bit more information
about our story so we created the
company in 2012 so at the beginning it
was just three guys we were not in a
garage because in France people work in
an office you know and we we studied at
the time where when the Google cloud
platform did not even exist so at that
time it was called App Engine and it was
a very very new product but you know
when we started we didn't have the
necessary financial resources and all
the time not the people to rely on our
own infrastructure and we would just
want it to build our product and that's
why we chose App Engine which was at the
time the only fully managed platform
available so we started a company with a
Java stack but we quickly move to Python
because we loved the simplicity of using
it and we really like Google
technologies at new maps so we adopted
angularjs at the same time and we built
an open-source framework which is called
Lumix
it's like material design for angularjs
it's open source so you should check it
out and you know since then more and
more companies have been using our
product our team has been growing our
App Engine invoice also has been growing
bigger months after months but that's
good news and you know when Google
recommended us at the end of last year
or when a big customer like via Vallejo
with 50,000 employees went live we
should have been scared will it work
will the platform run under such a load
the answer is yes and you know
we add like the most boring go live ever
so we were just in front of our
computers looking at the platform going
to explode and it just works and and you
can go live on a huge number of people
and and the platform will work so as you
can see we've been relying on almost
only the standard app engine from the
beginning and we've been adding some
pieces along the way so our bacon is in
pison and we use all the niceties from
Google App Engine so we use the cache
system we use the native integration
with cloud datastore which is a no
sequel database and we use the queuing
system you know to endow a large task
that you want to - - to run in the in
the background we also use Cloud
endpoints which is a framework to build
some API so you have all the O's -
authentication built in it's the same
technology that runs the API on all the
Google product so drive gmail calendar
and so on and it's used by all our
clients - the web Android iOS and all
our customers while doing some you know
custom integration using the API so my
diagram here is not totally accurate
because we have some pcs running outside
of App Engine so for instance we have a
small cluster of elasticsearch I will
explain after why we have this and we
also have some machine learning pieces
which are running on compute engine and
with this you know we can interact with
external services so that can be all the
drive API Calendar API Gmail API as well
as other third parties
we also plan on integrating with
firebase for real-time into notification
and directions in the product you know
so you can do pretty much everything
with App Engine but sometimes when you
use it you will it like a roadblock and
you you have to ask this question should
I move away from App Engine should I go
down the stack add to container engine
or compute engine
well is this happened to us at various
occasions and we always had to come up
with like a pragmatic solution to handle
these situations so let me tell you the
story of our search engine for instance
so we use it's built on top of the App
Engine Search API and some surgeries API
so the App Engine Search API is really
great
it allows you to index documents and do
complex queries at scale it's fully
managed and and don't get me wrong it
just worked so for us it was like the
perfect search system so we started
using it in production back in 2012 and
at this time it was like an alpha
product so it was very very new but it
has always worked for us except when you
do some very complex queries which
exceed two thousand bytes and when you
do that it just doesn't work and so this
is the limit but we needed more because
we have some very complex queries to run
but this is a very small fraction of our
queries so the question was should we
remove the Search API for those queries
and the answer was no we will just
create a small elastic search cluster
and index the documents twice and for
the small fraction of queries that do
not work with the Search API we will use
the elastic shots cluster instead and
this cluster run on compute engine and
is the same with the API
the Cloud endpoints framework is really
great to expose your API and have a way
for people to interact with it online
but it doesn't come with a good
documentation system yet so we had to
act a way into creating such a portal
but as the framework for Cloud endpoints
open source we were able to to just
create this portal using this open
source libraries and so just a few lips
tips if you if you want to be using App
Engine efficiently the first thing that
you should read the manual there are
some very good stuff in the
documentation from from Google
especially the English version which is
more up-to-date you shouldn't be afraid
to use services that are really really
new because they work so we use some
service in alpha mode and it was just ok
you should subscribe to the mailing list
from App Engine because there is some
really good stuff here and you can get
some some good information and the last
point is not obvious but you should pay
for support because sometimes when you
are in production you will have some
issues and you want the support team to
give you some answers very quickly so
everything is great great with App
Engine but we have a few challenges
today so the first one is about
measuring and debugging so App Engine
comes with a stack driver which a lot of
features to do some some logging some
analytics on the codes on debugging so
it's really great it's really good to
have access to all the logging system
and to be able to to search inside the
logs but sometimes you need more you
need to have an agent installed on the
most on the machine and you cannot you
can't do this with with standard so for
instance if you want to use a tool like
New Relic or that
you won't be able to do it with develop
and just stand down and you will have to
move to to flex then we have some I
wouldn't say issues but sometime it can
be tricky to have your application
working in in some countries especially
in China where App Engine is not like
the the best tool over in this countries
you have some some quotas also so for
instance if you intend to run to send a
lot a lot very large number of emails
you will be limited on App Engine
because they want to prevent you know
spam and so on so keep in mind those
those quotas and if you need more you
should consider using an Excel service
instead for the database so you have
cloud datastore which is really a good
tool but you you need to know how to use
it because if you use it as a sequel
database you it will just not work so
keep in mind that it's designed for a
scale and that there is some trade-off
when you design your data model and if
you do that you can really have
something which with which will scale
with no limit and the last point is
about moving from standard to flags
so as Brian was saying if you want to to
move from one to another you need to
read the couple the services that you
are using because natively on standard
you can use the cache system the cue
system and if you and the data store and
you you cannot do this directly using
the same libraries on flex so you you
know you there are some trade-off on how
you can move from from one to to the
other and you know finally let's talk
about the new stuff that we are walking
on so the first one is cloud spanner and
this one is really exciting
it offers the scalability of a managed
database but with the flexibility of
sequel so we will implement it for
complex objects with relationships where
the cloud data store is maybe too
limited for for this it's not the right
tool we also want to implement a
multiple multi region infrastructure
because we have instances in multiple
regions in App Engine and natively you
there is no like a load balancer on top
of all these regions you have to do it
on your own and so we are looking at the
best way to aggregate all of the
instances under same infrastructure and
finally so our dream a tree Maps is to
build a personal assistant for employees
and to be proactive to serve the right
information to the right people at the
right time and to do that we've studied
implementing machine learning algorithms
and we want to intensify the usage and
build on top of cloud ml to scale our
models and refine our data and so
finally when I prepare for this
presentation Brian asked me a question
he said if you had to make the decision
today would you make the same decision
and the answer is yes you know App
Engine has been really Apfel along the
way and frankly I'm not sure I would be
here today if we had not make this
choice five years ago so today we serve
1.5 million users with only one person
doing some DevOps in the team so it's
you know we we were able to really focus
on building the product which is great
what we could have done better is the
decoupling between standard appengine
features to make sure that it's easy to
switch from one system to another from
standard to flex to container engine and
to compute engine that's all thank you
you
[Applause]